Herkese
merhaba ben de size Melike Demir
Bir
[Alkış]
Hikayem İnsanların büyük oranda
geçimlerini Zeytincilik şarapçılık ve
balıkçılıkla sağlıkları Tekirdağ'a bağlı
bir sahil Kasabası olan müreftede
başlıyor
benim hatırlayamadım erken çocukluk
döneminde babamın işleri nedenle Tamam o
taşındık Ancak böyle bağımız hiç kopmadı
uzun yaz tatilleri boyunca ve kısım her
fırsatta sola yine müreftede alırdık
köyde paten ve kaykay da dolaşırken
uzaylı muamelesi görmek çocuk beğendim
ancak şehirde ya partman dairesine
balkonda domates çeşit yetiştirip kış ve
ilkbaharda
civciv yetiştirip bunları yazınız ve
tavuk olarak götüren o çocukla yine
bendim
her iki kültüre davet olmayan ya da
hareketini de kapsayan birleştiren yaşam
farzedelim ki
bir kimsede sayısal bölümü mezunu Pek
çok genç gibi Ben uzun uzadıya
düşünmeden mühendis olmaya karar verdim
Yıldız Teknik Üniversitesi makine
mühendisliği bölümünden mezun oldum ve
mezuniyetin ardından mekanik tesisat ve
köründe üç sene kadar ve ardından da
otomotiv sektöründe yaklaşık üçte ne
kadar çalıştım
ancak Bak her şey makinası yapıldığı
halde neden bu kadar çok çalışmak
zorunda olduğumuz Anlamıyorum neden
gecede gücünüz var diyorlar boyunca hiç
durmadan üretmek zorunda olduğumuzu
ve Nereye gittiğimizi tam olarak
kestiremiyorum ve Bence şirketlerin
hükümetlerin başına kişilerde tam olarak
nereye gittiklerini bilmiyorlar Çünkü
eğer öyle olsaydı iklim krizi fark
edildiğinde buna sebep olan faaliyetleri
bu son verildi ancak ne yazık ki krizi
tetikleyen Sanayi ve tarım
faaliyetlerini artan bir hızla devam
ediyoruz
de inanmadım bir yerde başarıya da mutlu
Olamazdım işten ayrılmaya karar verme
sürekli bütün kaygılarıyla sancılarıyla
ve kendi kendine kavgalarıyla oldukça
zordur benim için ve bir gün aynı dan
sürekli daha fazla araba üretmeyi
amaçlayan müşteri odaklı kalite
anlayışıyla çok ileri olduğunu savunan
işimi bırakmaya karar verdim
artık
bir maaşım yoktu her ayın başında yatan
sağlık sigorta astım üstümü Hanım hiçbir
şey yoktu Ancak pişmanlığın da yoktu şu
Çünkü bu yolun sonu gördüğümde kariyer
basamaklarını Çaybaşı artırmayı başarmış
olan müdürlerinin çıkıp oturdukları
yüksek makamlara ilgimi çekmiyordu
kendi adıma bir ömür bunu alacağım ve
değmezdi Benim yolum başkaydı ve ve
kendi kişisel MP bulmalıyım Bunu
düşündüm
ya Ben kimim nereden geldim ve ne için
geldim oraya ya gördüğünüz gibi
hayvanları çıktığına geldim
[Alkış]
sen bana her zaman iyi gelen doğada
biraz vakit geçirince bu soruları
cevapları kendinden İçime doğdu
selanikten mübadele yıllarında büyük
acılarla gelir et yerleşmiş olan
babaannelerin dikmiş olduğu ağaçlarla
zeytin ağaçlarıyla köyde akrabamız
ilgileniyor bize şehirde daha önemli
diye nitelendirdiğimiz başka işlerin
peşinde koşuyorduk okulları okumak
Kariyer yapmak başka başka bir şeyler ve
benim için asıl önemli olanın biyopsi
Toprak olduğumu anladığımda köye gittim
Ben yıllardır bahçesinde oynadım
dağlarına salıncaklar kurduğum çocukluk
arkadaşım zeytin ağaçlarının altında kim
olduğunu anlamaya çalıştım onları
tanımaya çalıştım
şimdi bu Ağaçlar nasıl canlılarda
çiçekleri ne zaman açardı nasıl kokardı
ve neye ihtiyacı vardır Bu avuçlarım
Kadir Zeytin ağacını köydeki
Büyüklerimizden öğrenmeye çalıştığım da
da kimyasal gübreler ve örüldü
pestisitler merhaba dedi bana Toprak
acımasızca sürüyordu ve toprağın üstünde
zeytin ağacından başka tek bir ağacın
tek bir okulun çiçeği kuşun böceğini hiç
birşey olmadığı hasta benim kültür
sistemin içinde buldum kendimi ve belki
de fabrikada araba üretmek Bu sistemin
içinde bir zeytin ağacı yetiştirmek var
çok daha ekolojik ti
bir Doğada Tek başınalığın sürüklenmiş
Her canlı tükenir ve tüketir bir mesela
kafeslere kapattığımız tavuklar mesela
hektar larca genişlikte arazilerde tek
başına yetiştirilen mısırlar sadece tek
başına yetiştirilen Buğdaylar
Ayçiçekleri veya bir metrekare alanda
çalışmak zorunda kalan fabrikalarda
çalışan işçiler ve yavrular Biraz daha
büyük masalarda bilgisayar başındaki
beyaz yakalar ya da yanında tek bir
okulları bulunmasına izin verilmeyen
Zavallı zeytin ağaçları
aynıyız aynı yerdeyiz
Şimdi biz buna insan da dahil olmak
üzere kendi türüne hapsolmuş Her canlı
hastalığa ve yok oluşan attım
tarım gibi masum gözüken en temel
işkolunun türleri nasıl da
yalnızlaştığını ve bunun sonucunda
ekosistem nasıl dağılma devam ettiğini
gördükçe ve
bu alanda üstüme düşen her neyse benim
görevim Her neyse bunu yapmak zorunda
olduğum anladım ve ve son birkaç yılımı
burada ne gerekiyorsa onu yapmak için
Geçiriyorum
ve Tabi ki Her şey bu kadar kötü ve
karanlık değil iyi şeyler de var Umut da
var benim tutunduğu Umut
toprağın karbon tutma kapasitesi ile
iklim değişikliği tersine
çevirebileceğimiz öğrendiğinde ha
mamasıyla dışarı fırlayan Arşimet gibi
ben herkese bunu anlatmak istedim Ancak
sözlerin telsizde şimdi kimse bunun bu
kadar kolay olabileceğine inanmak
istemiyordu Evet yapmamız gereken şey
kolayda ve ancak anlatması bir o kadar
zor Duygu anlatayım ben bir de burada
döneceğim
en basit şekliyle etkiler karbondioksiti
alıyor ve oksijen atmosfere sağlıyor
yani havadan iki oksijen Bir karbon
alanı bitki Bunun iki oksijen atmasıyla
geri verirken Bu şekilde bir bir karnını
tutuyor bu bir Karbonun 160 ile büyürken
yüzde kırkanın toprağı kökleri
vasıtasıyla yüzlerce metre Derine
görünüyor
bitkilerin temel işlevini yerine
getirebilmesi için neler yapmam
gerektiğini anlamıştım Öncelikle toprağa
sürmeyi bıraktım Çünkü bu işlem toprak
ve toprak mikrobiyolojisi ne inanılmaz
zarar veriyor ortopne
ve içindeki mikroorganizmalar ve su ile
canlı Yapı
ancak modern tarım ve maden tanı
yöntemlerine maruz kalmış Topraklar bu
canlılıktan nasibini alamıyor
şu çünkü
bu
tespitler ve kimyasal gübreler bu canlı
bu kendi bağışıklığını sağlayan çok
sistemini harap ediyor ve bu durumda
bitki daha fazla senteze ihtiyaç duyduğu
fazla kimyasal bir de ihtiyaç duyuyor ve
Yıllar Boyunca sürekli katlanarak artan
bir üretim ve her bir üretim
metrekaresine düşen katlanarak artan bir
kimyasal ihtiyacı içerisine bir döngüye
gitmiş oluyor şu Tüm bu tarım sektörü ve
bu şekilde toprağı sürmek kimyasal
zehirler atma ve sentetik gübre
döngüsüyle birbirini destekleyen günümüz
sorumlu değil oluşuyor ve hatta yetmiyor
atılıp tohumların ve
Bu akıllı doğum yapılır bu devlet
antikya maruz kalınca işlevini yerine
getiremedikleri için genetiğiyle
oynanmış tohumlarda Bu sistemin içine
giriyor ve ve her şey daha da içinden
çıkılmaz bir hale geliyor yavaş yavaş ve
bunların Son bulacağını Toprak ölü bir
kum yığınına dönüşüyor ve karbon ve su
tutma kapasitesi iyice düşen Toprak
atmosfere karbon salmaya başlıyor Yani
biz basit bir tatlı Toprak sürme
yerinden bu noktalara kadar gelebiliyor
uzem
bu ve toprak sürmeye bırakmak benim
kendi küçük devrimidir
bunu kullanmayı bırakınca ağaçların
altında kendiliğinden yabani ot iyi
geçtiğimiz Oo ısırgan madde bilmeceler
ve daha niceleri meydana çıktı
be adına ne kadar yabancı denize adına
başkaları en çok ait olan oraya en çok
yakışan larda bu yara türlerde
Ayrıca azot bağlama kapasitesi yüksek
olan Baklagiller çekerek bu yaratırlar
zeytin ağaçları ve diğer ağaçlar
toprakta kökler ile beraber hep birlikte
nefes almaya başladılar ve kendi
ekosistemlerinin kurdular
bu
ve bu Toprak sağladık kavuştuğu zaman
artık tarım zehirlenme ihtiyaç kalmıyor
burada bir montaj görüyoruz web-app
biyologlardan ki mantarın kendiliğinden
alıyorum bundan sonra ortaya çıktığı
ekosistemler Aslında güzel çalışmak o
sistemlerde Bu da bahçemizin kaç sene
önceki denetimi bu burada bir 3-4 sene
var Sanıyorum aşağıdan insan ayında
zeytin Pamuklu bitirdi denilen bir
hastalık konuşun üstünde ve onun ya uğur
böceği görüyorsunuz ama biz de
Erberk kimyasal ilaçlar kullanıyoruz
aldık zaten bu uğurböceği görecekti ve
bu sistem kendini kuramayacak Yani biz
bıraktığımız zaman daha fazla bir şeyler
ve düzeltmeye çalalım da bıraktığımız
zaman ya da daha çok verim elde etmeye
bıraktığımız zaman doğayı kendi ara
bıraktığımız zaman o bir şekilde kendi
evresinde buluyor bizim yapmamız gereken
aslında gözlemlemek onu anlamaya
çalışmak ve ona uyum sağlamaya çalışmak
bir yerde ve bu da yavaşlamayı bir
sürprizle biraz geride bırakmayı da
gerektiriyor Aslında
ve moleküler leşten da çıkarak bak
Zeytinli geçirdiğini bildiğimiz incir bu
adam Defne açılarda diktim
Ayrıca sentetik gübre yerine de
zeytinin en yakın dostu olan keçilerin
gübresini kullandık burada bir konusu
görüyoruz elimde kepçeyle koşan benim
oğlum
insanda bu ekoloji içinde bizde araba
yerde değiliz
ağaç ot hem
kadın erkek atlet hepiniz bütün
parçaları oluşturuyoruz ve çok değerli
bir sistem var binlerce yıldır sürüp
giden Neden onu son yüzyılda bu kadar
her şey değişti biz ne yaptık Neyi bu
kadar hızlı değiştirdik ve kutunun sonu
nerede görmesi Aslında çok kolay ve bu
yaptığımız yavaş artık fark eden
farkedip Bundan sonra ne yapabiliriz
daha eskiden ne oluyordu Yani bizim çok
çok yeni tekno O değil de belki 100 sen
öylesine bir dönüp bakma ya biraz daha
ihtiyacımız olabilir diye düşünüyorum şu
menestrel tarım alanlarının ve
endüstriyel hayvancılığın birbirinden
ayrılmış olması Hele ki mekanizmanın da
ayrı ayrı carbon-carbon sağlığı
makinalarına dönüşmesine neden oluyor
Halbuki hayvancılık ve tarım çok çok
eskiden beri olduğu üzere bir arada
olduğu zaman kendi sistemlerini
kuruyorlar ve toprağın karbonat unu
kapasitesini daha dağıtıyorlar
bu yıllarca monokültürel marsak
Yalnızlığa mahkum edilmiş sayısını
açıları şimdi bu ekosistem içinde
sürüngenler Kuşlar Böcekler kemirgenler
ve bizden hep bir aradalar ve
bir tek başına bütün olarak zevkli
zeytin ne kadar zayıf ve güçsüz
s1o sistemin içindeki zeytin
hastalıklara karşı diyor kadar dirençli
güçlü verimli ve bereketli oluyor
sağlığına İşte bu biyolojik çeşitlilikte
Nalan bahçemizde yeniden hoş çubukları
ve aramızda okulları dönüyor başladık
zeytin
ve üretimi burada her şekilde daha
farklı oluyor ve belki de son babaannem
demişti bu sesleri yıllardır bomboş
sadece ağacın olduğu ve altında bırakın
toprağın oldu bir tane Hadi burası ve
Zeytin zeytinyağı ve zeytinyağlı sabun
üretimi küçük işletmenin adına
Babaanneme doğru olan saygısından
çocukluğundan beri Hayran Olduğum ismini
vermek istedim mesela
bir
[Alkış]
bahçemiz özelinden çıkıp iklim konusunda
dönecek olursak
325 için sebep olan temel faktör
atmosferdeki karbon dökülür
2012 yılında yayınlanmış olan
WhatsApp'ın sattığı warming isimli
makale de
ki alıntıya göre
bir Önümüzdeki birkaç olmalı içinde
tamamen yenilenebilir enerji
kaynaklarına geçecek
dahia sana devrimin başlangıcından bu
yana atmosfere sarmış olduğumuz 1 milyar
ton karbon yükü atmosferde asıl durmaya
havada asılı durmaya devam edecek
yanlış ay burada ne demek istiyor ama
yani bir
yeni teknolojilerle
elektrikli arabalarla rüzgar türbinleri
ile güneş panelleri ve bilimun yeni bir
edebileceğimiz teknolojilerle iklim
krizi ile başa çıkma bilmemiz Şu an için
mümkün görünmüyor Çünkü atmosferde asılı
kalan yukarıdan yükünün önüne
geçebilirsiniz için bu karbonat toprağa
geri vermek Şu an içimizin tek Kurtuluş
olduğunuz gibi görünüyor
ve dünyada tarım yöntemlerinin neredeyse
tamamen kimyasala dönüş olduğu Son 50-60
Yıl içinde Biz yüzey toprağımızın üçte
birini kaybettik
yani şu anki kaynağı tarım uygulamaları
nedeniyle yanlış tarım uygulamaları
nedeniyle hızla çok yaşıyoruz iklimi
kriz yaşıyoruz ve sağlığımızı
kaybediyoruz Birleşmiş Milletler Gıda ve
Tarım Örgütü'nün
verilerine göre
ama biz kalan yüzey toprağının
Önümüzdeki altmış yıl içinde yok olacağı
öngörülüyor Yani bu demek oluyor ki biz
arıyorum onlarla tarım yapmaya devam
edersek son 69 kaldı bu vahim tablo
topraksız tarım yandığı için çok tabi
olduğunu ifade etmiyor Olabilir çünkü
teknoloji kullanarak yarattığı sorunları
yeni teknolojiler yaratarak
Çözebileceğimiz düşünüyoruz zaman zaman
ama nasıl teknolojiler yani saniye güneş
panelleri ile mi kaplıcalı yapay zekanın
bizi kurtaracak Biz hep beraber varsa mı
taşınacağım ya da belki sadece zenginler
yani doğanın Bizim onu korumamıza
ihtiyacı yok aslında bunu fark etmemiz
gerekiyor doğalın bizim ona vermiş
olduğumuz zararı artık bir son vermemize
ihtiyacı var Aslında
Bu bir daha fazla bir şeyler yapmazsak
Belki çok daha hayırlı olacak o güzel
ormanlık alanların içine 12 siteleri
yapmazsak heryere AVM kurmazsak Her
gördüğümüz sefer bir rüzgar türbini
kundurma saat heryere barajlar yapmazsak
bu
ön Merak ettim de tarım zehir bulunmayan
gıdaların üzerine organik etiketi
yapıştırıp fahiş fiyatlarla küçük bir
zümrenin huzuruna sormasak mesela Çünkü
içinde tarım değeri bulunmayan gıdalar
herkesin hakkı bu bilgisayar
O çocuk sen de ayaklarımızın altında
duruyor
bu Toprak kadar güvenli öğrenerek onun
kendini iyileştirme kapasitesine saygı
duyup onunla işbirliği yaparak hem
sağlığınızı hem de toprağın sağlığını
koruyabiliriz
toprağı kalitesi üstünde yetişen ve
dağınık haritasını belirliyor ve bir
sofra zehirleyerek sağlıklı kiloya
birleşemiyoruz sağlıklı gezen de
yazacağım yaşayamıyoruz da sağlıklı olur
muyuz biz bunu son on yıllardır
deniyorum ve artık bulmadığını görme
zamanı bunu bu tarım yöntemine bırakma
zamanı geldi
Yok canım sağlığıyla gezegenin sağlığım
Budan bu tane bu 16'da olduğunu bilmek
tüm dünya aksini söylesede hep bana ne
yapacağını söyleyen ilk sesini dinleme
konusunda
yardımcı oluyor çünkü o zaman doğruyu
söylüyor Biz hepimiz aynı bütünün
parçalarıyız şu anda yaşamakta olan
türler ve onun geçmiş ve gelecek bütün
nesiller olarak aynı özelliğiniz
Allah bizi bitki yediğinizde Ondaki
maddeler bizim hücrelerimiz tarafından
tanınıyor bizim hücrelerimiz aynı dili
konuşuyor bu mucizevi bir şey ve mucize
onu arıyor Gözlerim baktığı her yerde
aslında
Bu bir yaptığınız Her seçim ile yıkımına
yol açtığımız ya da koruduğumuz odağın
kendisi olduğunu anladığımız vakit doğa
koruma diye bir şey de kalmayacak
bu iklim kredinin tersine çevirmek için
kuşaklar sonraki sorunlarımızın ormanda
yürürken bir mesaj dalında öten bir
kızıl gördüğün sesini dinle bilmeleri
için
bu ve sentetik olmayan gerçek gıdalar ve
beslenebilmesi için tarım yöntemleri
mize hemen değiştirmeyi seçelim canım
anadolumuz da Kurda kuşa Haa aşağıda
suyla bağda bahçede harman yerinde
Birlik bilinci içinde doğadaki her Canan
saygıyla dokunan bir kültürden geliyoruz
ve bu tür konuşmaları her zaman Ümit var
bir şekilde bitirmek gerekiyor
Şu Doğa Biz de birazdan yani usulüyle
bütün konuşmalarımız daha bizlere Biraz
önce ve o korumaya çalıştığımız ya da
yaptığınızı söylediniz O da biz Evet ve
Umut gerekiyorsa eğer o mutlaka bizi
iklimde biziz kristal dizisi ve
bunlardan hangisi olacağımıza karar
verecek olan da inebiliriz
[Alkış]
dünyada döneminde yaptığımız her seçimde
sorunun bir parçası olabiliriz krize
neden olabiliriz ya da biz çözümün
parçası olabiliriz
şansımız varsa biz ne diyoruz Eğer bir
gücümüz varsa biz hangi üreticileri
destekliyoruz
o
Peygamberimize ya da kasıtlı eğlen
sildiğimizde Biz içimizdeki doğa ile
Şuradaki Doğu arasındaki uyumu göz
atıyoruz
mı beni Ben kadınların açtığın sesini
dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]